صباح الخير صباح الجمال صباح الحب صباح
الجميع الاشياء التي موجوده هنا على هذه
البقعه من الارض جميله نصبح بها عليكم ولا
نبخل عساكم ان تكونوا بالف خير
اجمل ما في الدنيا الجمال الله سبحانه
وتعالى اعطانا احنا الجمال دون ان يبخل
علينا فتعالوا نتفكر ونتحسس ونتلمس قيمه
الجمال في ملكوت الله القمر الشمس البحر
الشجر كلها جمال فقط علينا ان نبصر ونتبصر
في كيفيه الجمال وكيفيه عمليه تقييمنا
للجمال عسى ان نريح نفوسنا عشان نسترخي
عسى ان نحب كما ينبغي عسى ان نجد عمليه
التعامل المشترك والعيش المشترك مع بعض
هذا سر الجمال بشكل عام
المسرح له نصيب وكبير جدا من الجمال الذي
ينحط على الخشبه المسرح يستفيد منه ذاك
المخرج او انا كمخرجه او ذاك الممثل ينعكس
بعمليه ايجابيه على خشبه المسرح
الفازه الجميله الذي هي موجوده على خشبه
المسرح تعطي لمسه جماليه مبهره علي ان
اعرف كيف علي ان اتعامل مع هذه الفازه
وكيف علي ان استشعرها انا احس بها لان
الجمال هو احساس احساس صادق
ناتي الى الجانب الثاني الفن عند الكبر
يعني انا عمري 60 سنه واو كثير
عجز طيب الفن عند الكبار
كل ما كبرنا كل من دارتنا كل ما فهمنا
اكثر كل ما عشقنا الحياه وتمسكنا بها في
ناس وصلوا الى هذا العمر مثل عمري
وحسوا بالانطوائيه
الاكتئاب القوقعه في بقعه ما
ليه انت قادر تعطي انت الله اعطالك هذا
المخ واعتق قلب صحيح اذا انت بني ادم قادر
على العطاء لطالما انت قادر على العطاء
علا وعسى عطاءك هذا يؤثر يغير وتتاثر به
امم ليس فرد ولا افراد بل امم يا جماعه
كذاب من قال ان اليد الوحده لا تصفق لا
تصفق
تصفق هذه كتله هوائيه اهو
لكن بيدين نصفق
بثلاث
التصفيقه تكون ذات ايقاع وصداع اهو
فتعال حط يدك على يدي لكي تاخذ تجربه سنين
عمري من العمل المسرحي وانقلها لك لكي
تعمل وتجد وتستطيع ان تصنع ذاتك ان تصنع
دراما صحيحه اني استغرب هناك اناس يستحو
وبعضهم في استحياء بالشيء لان العقل
الباطني سبحان الله يخزن ويخزن ويخزن تجي
لحظه تقول له انت تعرف تمثل يقول لك لا
تردد في تردد بالمساله التردد هذا في يوم
وليله ده نتيجه تراكمات نفسيه عاشها في
بيئته الف في البيت
انعكست هذا بعد ان شاب الشخص على مجتمعه
علياء ان يساعد ان اعطي يد امد يد
المساعده حتى انتشر هذا المخلوق الطموح
جميل جميل ان نطبح جميل ان نحلم جميل جدا
ان نعشق احلامنا ولكن كيف علينا ان نحققه
لن تتحقق لبيد اخرى تساعد ذاك الحالم حتى
يصير في موقعي ويؤثر على المجتمع ويتاثر
انصاف علوي
كاسم ما تعنيش حقيقه لا تعنيني بشيء ولكن
ماذا عملت انصاف علوي هذا ما يعنيني الفعل
هل اثرت على المجتمع من خلال اعماله في
مرحله العمليه كامله على خشبه المسرح اثرت
على المجتمع عملت شيء ملموس نعم
منذ 30 35 سنه
وانا اجتهد وشقي واتعب اسافر هنا المطارات
تعبت مني من المهرجانات من المناقشات من
محاضرات الى في النهايه انصرف على وتم
تكريمها فاول مخرجه يمنيه
عالميه تم تكريم صف علوي فاول مخرجه
يمنيه على مستوى الجزيره والخليل فرحانه
بالتكريم كالقابك شهاده فرحانه في بس هل
هذا التكريم اعطاء مردود ايجابي على
مجتمعي اتمنى ان يكون ادى هذا التكريم
واجبه كما ينبغي
الان نحن في القرن 21 الناس اجتهدت كثير
حبل كبار السن من الممثلين ومن المخرجين
في ادبك كثيرين يكتب الكبار السن لماذا
نحن لا نكتب لكبار لماذا نحن لا نحترم
كبار السن من المبدعين لا ادري سؤال اتمنى
ان نجد لو ذات يوم اجابه وواضحه وقريئه
ولكن اقدر اقول ان احنا علينا ان نحافظ
على الدراما لكي تعمل مفعوله لتغيير
المجتمع المجتمع لا يمكن يتغير الا لو كان
في حرق ثقافي فني كما كان في السابق كادت
عدن من ارى للدرامه مناره للموسيقى مناره
للادب يا جماعه لا يجب ان نبقي هكذا انتهى
دور المسرح انتهى الممثلين والمخرجين خلاص
نجلس يداكنا على خدوكم رحم الله علان
وفلتان لا
هكذا نبكي على السينما كمال
كانت عندنا ثمن راسنا ما بلقيس وسينما
لا لماذا لا نتفاعل جميعا ونصنع نصنع في
بلدنا سينما ذات خصوصيه مميزه لماذا لا
نثبت ونتشبت في تثبيت احلامنا ليبقى
المسرح ويا السينما وهي التلفزيون كما كان
في السابق بل هو اعظم لدينا مؤلفين لدينا
سعيد علقي لدينا كان موجود محمود اربد
لدينا اسماء منيره في الوطن العربي لدينا
مخرجين علي يافعي
انصاف علوي الى الك من الاسماء لدينا
ممثلات وممثلين ذكرى احمد علي
نرقص عباد كثير كثير من الاسماء الا
نستطيع اكراما لهؤلاء الننير بلادنا الا
نستطيع ان نجعل بلدنا مناره كما كانت
اعتقد اننا كلنا نعشق بلدنا ويجب ان تكون
بلدنا مادارا كما كانت
في الختام في الختام
اقدر اقول انها عدن غاليه عاليه زي ما
غاليه على كل الناس وعليكم غاليه جدا
ومازلت اعطي الكثير والكثير سواء كان في
عدن او في بقعه اخرى عدا لن تمحيها
الذاكره ومحفوره في قلبي فاعطيها انا
الكثير واعطوها انتم معايا
ولندعل جميعنا عدن مناره للثقافه والفن
والفنون شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]